this is my first time voting
my first election and I'm more than excited
I feel like my goal is my voice and um
I'm just excited to have been able to use it and express exactly how I feel
who I feel but best represent me and those that I love and care around
It’s the perfect opportunity to exercise your right as a United States citizen
and it gives you
the power to
dictate your own future and for me
voting just means
it's important to me
it's important to the people that laid the groundwork for me to vote
as a black woman and the people future
if I plan on having kids
this affects them for sure
this affects all the communities that I care about
so I just feel voting is just a very important mechanism to um
just take control of your future
your past absolutely vote
you should absolutely vote
this is one of the most important elections that will come across
it's a historic moment and to be a part of history is an amazing thing
no matter whether you don't like either candidate
I feel like voting is so important for everyone around you
not just yourself like
this is not a selfish moment at all
like this is a pivotal moment for the entire country
everyone you love and care about
so it is so important to go out and vote and act like
use your right as citizen what power you have